hey guys Ryan Wright is here and Jerry
is also present so a photo of the Joker
was released and people are definitely
asking us hey Ryan and Jerry could you
guys get together and do a video about
this photo it's Anarchy out there
introducing a little Anarchy hey let's
talk about this photo yeah this is
exactly what the internet needs is more
dudes talking about not much information
there's another detail in it it's not
like oh here's a costume I like the
artwork we're seeing on his body well
he's like a sexy Joker isn't it I feel
like I'm gonna be in the minority of
this one but I really like this I like
while you're in the minority I love it
Oh a lot of people are angry about yeah
[ __ ] them this image has been out for
like all of three hours and people are
already not happy about this at all it
does look like the punk rock version of
the Joker I'm okay with it I'm glad I
already see this photo and I'm like
thank God it's not Heath Ledger's like
you know like I love geek ledger but the
thing that would suck if it's like
they're trying to make him eat ledger
okay yeah like I'm super down for
something different and weird that's
what I see when I look at this I see
like wacky psycho and I'm excited about
that and I like the tats man he's got
like the lips big-ass teeth the mouth is
what they call it and they got the she
was that called again like a gesture
like a gesture I know exactly that word
I've heard before yesterday like like in
the king's court he would have a chest
make me laugh fool ah
so again Joker the hahaha everywhere and
he's cut he's a cut Joker yeah or or at
least he's you know very very senior you
know he looks cutting there yeah he
looks cut those look like muscles very
small nipples
very nice chest though really defined my
god I looked at like those tits his face
I mean I know he's got a mouth wide open
like know and that's what's great about
it too like the Joker doesn't work if
they look like the actor and he's got a
grill - you got a grill yeah
the hamburgers and [ __ ] me I think it's
a great like self-awareness photo of the
Joker you know but I think it's a really
good photo I like day then okay Joker's
hair last time was long let's make his
short like he was going for a lot of the
opposite things you know like Joker
before he feel like a Heath Ledger was
like known for the clothes he was
wearing is they all right I'll go
shirtless on this vote who you know yeah
like I like the promotion they're going
for it here yeah if I was to do
something different and wild and weird
in it I feel like this is the tactic
this is what they're doing is like
they're basically like let's put out
this image because I think they know
people are gonna lose their [ __ ] over
this yeah and so now it's people were
talking about the movie people are
buzzing about the movie in advance and
we're gonna have enough time to get
acclimated to this look so that by the
time the movie comes out because like
like I said I was online before this and
like most people seem very upset about
it we've had a lot of unlikely things
happen before where people are like no I
this is not gonna be any good and then
it was fine
get ready for the comments because a lot
of people are gonna be like anyway guys
if you knew the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects cherry has
a playlist on this channel the reasons
to Gerry you give also Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where we're
constantly showing pictures of our
rock-hard abs and pecs buh buh buh buh
Mortal Kombat Theme song